[Musik]
der tag an dem ich wieder gehen und
rennen kann wird der beste tag meines
lebens
das ist mein traum wird wahr je wieder
gehen und rennen können
der krieg in syrien hat zwar seine
gesundheit geraubt hat ihm seine
kindheit geraubt um seinen vater seit
vier jahren tobt in syrien der
bürgerkrieg mehr als 200.000 menschen
kamen ums leben
diejenigen die über leben tun dies mit
unsäglichen verletzungen
körperlich und seelisch
[Musik]
basha der syrische flüchtlingsjungen der
sein leben zurückhaben will
davon erzählt diese geschichte
[Musik]
als wir das erste mal treffen ist der 14
jahre alt wir finden ihn in einem
kleinen raum in einem flüchtlingscamp
tier in beirut im libanon
ursprünglich stammt pauschal aus aleppo
da kam ein flugzeug und warf eine bombe
ich verlor mein bein und mein vater war
tot
kannst du das alles gesehen ja das habe
ich alles gesehen
wann war das medizinische behandlung
erhält war zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht
geschweige denn psychologische ich gehe
ab und zu zu einem arzt hier aber nicht
oft
wir können es uns nicht leisten weil sie
zu teuer
baschar lebt mit seiner familie in
schatila das ist jenes stadt gewordene
flüchtlingslager in beirut in welchem
seit jahrzehnten vorwiegend
palästinenser leben seit dem krieg in
syrien leben hier aber auch immer mehr
syrische flüchtlinge war hatte zum
zeitpunkt unseres ersten besuches
keinerlei hoffnung je wieder gehen zu
können uns jedoch ließ ein schicksal
keine ruhe
wir hielten kontakt und erfuhren drei
monate später von einem
hoffnungsschimmer
ein hilfswerk aus katar hatte baschar
eine beinprothese ermöglicht wir fahren
hin und treffen war in eine
rehabilitationsklinik südlich von beirut
da basars mutter sich nicht öffentlich
zeigt hat ihn lieblingsonkel daheim
begleitet vor 20 tagen haben sie mir
gesagt ich könne hierherkommen sie
wollten wir eine prothese anpassen
ich musste nur warten bis man beinahe
ein wenig besser geheilt war du schiebst
also neue hoffnung ja sehe ich will
laufen die rehabilitationsklinik ist
eine der modernsten in ganz libanon
sie ist spezialisiert auf komplizierte
prothesen zusammen mit physiotherapeut
ali alavi arbeitet baggio täglich auf
sein großes ziel hin
noch kann es sich nicht selber aus dem
rollstuhl erheben
geschweige denn mit der prothese ihren
als ich hierherkam sagte mir der doktor
nach einem monat kannst du fußball
spielen ich konnte es selbst kaum
glauben was er arbeitet hart
mehrere stunden täglich verbringt er
zusammen mit physiotherapeut ali im
gymnastikraum
sascha hat seine muskeln fast ein jahr
lang nicht mehr richtig bewegt viele der
übungen bereiten ihm schmerzen liegen
und hebt den fuß
er ist ein ehrgeiziger junger mann
er will so schnell wie möglich gehen
aber ist ein bisschen verwöhnt
verklagten wenig zu oft aber wir
arbeiten daran
wir nehmen schritt für schritt die ärzte
werfen war zu wenig auf die zähne zu
beißen
dabei gibt sich barca zumindest bei
unserem besuch offensichtlich mühe dank
der übungen mit dr ali kann ich immerhin
schon mal mein bein biegen
das konnte ich vorher licht war total
streifen als ich hierher kam begannen
wir mit den übungen
ich saß ja zuvor nur im rollstuhl
ich kann man bei uns sehen und ich kann
es wieder zurückkehren aber es waren
viele übungen nötig wir sind immer noch
im ersten stadium wenn er steht dann
steht er auf dem bein mit der prothese
auf seinem gesunden linken bein stehen
kann er noch nicht
das problem ist dass an sich gesunde
bein war ja früher auch gebrauchen
bedürfnis erst seit kurzem mit gewicht
belasten
jetzt klagt bar jeden morgen ist bmw
dabei ist das normal
männer zeigen schmerz in dieser
weltgegend sonst nicht offen
auch baschar versteckt seinen kummer
normal reise gern vor uns doch
irgendetwas stimmt ganz offensichtlich
nicht
physiotherapeut ali alavi und buses
insel der prothesen spezialist beginnen
zu zweifeln
vielleicht ist baschar der ja auch
traumatisiert ist doch nicht einfach nur
wehleidig neue röntgenbilder sollen
helfen was schmerzen zu verstehen als
erste mal auf diesen bein stand hat es
in das knie verdreht das war noch beim
vorherigen arzt also dann zu mir kam
hatte er starke schmerzen
er sagte mir er könne nicht auf dem bein
stehen er hatte angst aufzustehen
das röntgenbild liefert die erklärung
[Musik]
wir merkten etwas stimmt nicht wir
entschieden ihn zu einem guten arzt zu
schicken denn hier kann
wir warten nun röntgenbilder und siehe
da er hat erneut zwei brüche in seinem
gesunden bein ein buch direkt unterhalb
des knies und einen zweiten oberhalb des
mittels diese nachricht ist für basha
ein heftiger schlag
ich bin schockiert
ich komm doch hierher um wieder gehen zu
können
und jetzt sagen sie mir mein gesundes
bein sei gebrochen gebrochen
das ist doch nicht fahren was soll ich
denn jetzt machen
[Musik]
und es wird noch schlimmer hallo
ja ja ich bin sein onkel da
nein daran der eltern ja bitte ok gott
beschütze sie ja verstehen
wir packen das spital schickt uns nach
hause
sie sagen uns wir sollen nach hause
gehen
ich sollte zu meinem arzt schauen was
der st
[Musik]
ich bin traurig ich weiß nicht was mit
mir geschehen wird wir bräuchten geld
für eine operation aber ob wir das
zusammen kriegen
[Musik]
barca war gekommen um wieder gehen zu
lernen
stattdessen muss ihn sein onkel wieder
ins auto eben
[Musik]
das problem ist mascha bräuchte eine
operation um den doppelten beinbruch zu
heilen
doch eine operation ist teuer und geld
hat war keines
statt auf zwei beinen stolz nach hause
zu kommen trifft barca in schatila
wieder im rollstuhl ein
[Musik]
wartet ich will bei sharon lo sagen
schön bist du wieder da und sehen wir
dich in einer woche oder einen monat
hier rauf und runter rennen
ich habe
hier
das kommt schon gut auch wenn er es
nicht offen zeigt in barschels
gefühlswelt ist diese rückkehr eine
niederlage als ältester wollte er seiner
familie helfen
statt ihr weiter zu last zu fallen so
empfindet er das nämlich
[Musik]
ein weiterer onkel empfängt ihn zu hause
ich habe dich vermisst dich auch ich
will jetzt einfach so schnell wie
möglich operiert werden
ich will operiert werden dass alles
wieder gut wird
wir haben alle so gehofft dass er
zurückkommt und laufen kann die tränen
kann er nur mühsam zurückhaltend
in schatila beginnen für basha quälend
lange wochen ohne dass etwas geschieht
das leben im flüchtlingslager ist ohne
perspektive zur schule können baschar
und seine vielen cousins und cousinen
die mit ihm nach china geflohen sind
nicht im libanon gibt es inzwischen mehr
syrische flüchtlingskinder als
libanesische kennt die flüchtlinge
wissen ganz genau dass sie im libanon
kaum eine zukunft haben
ich möchte gehen können und dann
verreisen
ich will wieder zur schule gehen hier
gibt es nicht die schulen sind wir
können es uns nicht leisten
wir können ja kam die miete für diese
wohnung bezahlen schon seine
zehnjährigen kusa suchen verzweifelt
jobs sie müssen helfen die 45-köpfige
großfamilie über wasser zu halten
ich könnte vielleicht 20 dollar
verdienen 20 dollar pro tag
nein pro woche
so wie viele flüchtlinge auch meist
baschar ganz genau was er will
in den westen reisen das für dein leben
vollkommen verändern
dort kannst du an deine zukunft arbeiten
du kannst studieren du kannst dein haus
haben
hier gibt es all das nicht hier gibt es
keine zu klein
hier dreht sich mein ganzes leben darum
dass ich wieder gehen kann
wir verlassen uns beirut mit einem
gefühl der hoffnungslosigkeit
[Musik]
bis wir wieder einen anruf erhalten
zum glück wurden wir nicht im sechsten
stock ich bin so glücklich ist geht es
wieder los geht wieder vorwärts
warschau hat uns angerufen und zu sich
bestellt warum hat er uns nicht gesagt
es ist eine schöne überraschung
auch dank hilfe aus der schweiz konnte
war die operation bezahlen jetzt dafür
zurück in die reha klinik
[Musik]
wenn ich die prothese war kann ich dinge
tun die ich ganz lange nicht mehr tun
könnte laufen
das wird großartig doch nach allem was
das letzte mal passiert ist ist man
vorsichtig geworden
das ist das ranking bild vom letzten mal
diesmal wird alles gut
[Musik]
ich hoffe es
hey wie geht es dir ein bisschen besser
das ist der operationsbereich
[Musik]
du hast dann bei einem tripoli operiert
sie haben von hier etwas genommen dass
weiter unten eingesetzt
in der werkstatt arbeitet besser sind an
den prothesen auch diejenige von baschar
wird neu angepasst
schneide hier ein stück raus siehst du
so etwa muss das aussehen
dann musst du es hier ein passen für was
im winter ist das ein schwieriger
patient weil er mehr psychologe sein
müsste als prothesen spezialist doch
dann ist für baschar der moment gekommen
wo er seine ersten schritte machen soll
ohne sich mit beiden händen festzuhalten
noch zögert er aber dann
die ersten freien schritte seit zwei
jahren versuche nicht zu hinken einfach
geradeaus gehen genauso ja genau so
kommt das ist gut
das wichtigste ist baschar lächelt das
ist sehr gut
wir hoffen dass er noch ein wenig mehr
mut fasst dann kann er gehen und rennen
wie es eine form der auch bei sharp ist
schnell müde
ich mag
[Musik]
doch jetzt geht alles schnell baschar
soll schon bald nach hause zurückkehren
ich kann es kaum erwarten mein normales
leben zurück zu bekommen
rauszugehen und zu laufen das härteste
ist dass ich etwas tue was ich seit zwei
jahren nicht mehr gemacht haben
die ärzte müssen wir erst wieder bei
drängen zu gehen
ich wusste nicht mehr was ich wie
bewegen
[Musik]
du hast ja was mag kaum mehr
sitzenbleiben sitzt die prothese richtig
komm du kannst selber gehen
du machst es gut - das letzte mal
verließ baschar die klinik im rollstuhl
rausgeworfen weil er kein geld hatte
jetzt kann er aufrecht gehen
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich wir sind auf dem
heimweg und ich habe es geschafft ein
glücklicher tag
der glücklichste in meinem leben
wir haben so lange auf diesen tag
gewartet
[Musik]
in china wird pascha bereits erwartet
doch typisch barschaft er der zuvor
selbst in den traurigsten momente
gelächelt hatte ist jetzt im moment
seines größten triumphes zurück halten
und konzentriert
[Musik]
die großmutter hat für sascha extra ein
festmahl gekocht syrischen reis mit
mandeln und rosinen ein reiches mal für
die flüchtlingsfamilie die mutter von
warschau hat sich wie immer sofort
zurückgezogen als wir auftauchten
doch die cousins umschwärmen ihn
kinderstube muss war sein neues bein her
zeigen großvater onkel cousins und
cousinen sind da heute ist war der star
der familie endlich habe ich mein leben
wieder zurück kein unterschied mehr
zwischen den anderen kindern und mir
ich hoffe so sehr dass wir die zukunft
glück bringen das leben ist es ist
schwierig für uns
ich wünsche mir dass ich studieren kann
dass ich arbeiten kann
damit wir unser leben verbessern können
warschau der flüchtlings junge aus
aleppo er ist bereit für die ersten
schritte in ein neues leben
[Musik]